la culebrilla es una afección cutánea
dolorosa en adultos causada por el virus
de la varicela también conocido como
virus de la varicela zóster
si tuvo varicela cuando era niño
todavía tiene el virus de la varicela
zoster adentro de algunos de sus nervios
pero no de forma activa
por razones desconocidas el virus de la
varicela zoster puede reactivarse en
gente mayor en aquellas personas con el
sistema inmunológico debilitado
el virus reactivado viaja a lo largo de
los nervios hacia la piel y causa
síntomas como entumecimiento hormigueo
y dolor
estos síntomas son seguidos
inmediatamente por un sarpullido rojo
con ampollas
la culebrilla normalmente se produce en
una única área sobre uno de los costados
del cuerpo también puede producirse
sobre uno de los hombros sobre el
costado del cuello o de la cabeza
en un periodo de entre 3 y 5 días las
protuberancias en el sarpullido se
llenan de líquido y se convierten en
ampollas que se ven como varicela
luego las ampollas se llenan de pus y
esto provoca que se rompan
y comienza a formarse una costra
cuando las costras se caen las ampollas
cicatrizan y el dolor por lo general
desaparece
estos síntomas usualmente duran de 1 a 2
meses
puede sufrir una complicación derivada
de la culebrilla llamada neuralgia
postherpética o mph que es un dolor
incluso después de que el sarpullido se
cura
y otras complicaciones de la culebrilla
incluyen pérdida de visión si la
culebrilla se produce alrededor de los
ojos neumonía problemas auditivos
inflamación del cerebro problemas
neurológicos e infecciones cutáneas
tanto la vacuna contra la varicela como
la vacuna contra la culebrilla puedan
reducir radicalmente el riesgo de
contraer culebrilla y neuralgia
postherpética
aunque no hay cura para la culebrilla
los medicamentos antivirales como
aciclovir pueden acelerar la curación y
reducir la gravedad del sarpullido
cuando se toman dentro de los tres días
posteriores a la aparición del
sarpullido para reducir el dolor su
médico puede recomendarle analgésicos de
venta libre
loción de calamina
compresas frías y baños de avena
para la neuralgia postherpética grave su
médico le puede resultar medicamentos
como gabapentina